Lucas Black knows how to make an exit - and
so does NCIS: New Orleans.
Heads up - major spoilers ahead.
During the sixth episode of Season Six, called
"Matthew 5:9," Black's character Special Agent
Christopher LaSalle died after sustaining
gunshot wounds to his arm and stomach while
on a mission to avenge the death of his brother.
It's not easy to say goodbye to a key character
after six seasons, but it's comforting to
know that Black reportedly didn't depart from
NCIS: New Orleans on a whim or because of
any behind-the-scenes drama no one knew about.
Instead, Black exited the procedural for a
very important reason: to spend more time
with family.
In a video uploaded to the NCIS: New Orleans
YouTube channel, Black, who is married with
three children, explained his decision to
part ways with the CBS series.
He admitted that while the show has been,
quote, "so good to [him] over the years,"
the schedule wasn't always easy.
"There's a lot of priorities in my life that
get sacrificed for me to be here.
But it's time for me to focus on those priorities."
It may be tough for fans to accept a beloved
star has other priorities, but nothing but
love and support has surrounded Black's dramatic
exit from the show.
According to TV Insider, the NCIS: New Orleans
showrunners said in a statement,
"We had an amazing run with Lucas Black and
he has been such an important part of our
NCIS: New Orleans team.
We are sad to see him go, but happy he will
have more time to spend with his family."
High-profile stars might sometimes use "family"
as a fake excuse to exit an unwanted situation,
but Black's co-workers seem convinced that
his reasons are genuine.
C.C.H.
Pounder, who plays medical examiner Loretta
Wade, said in a video released by the show
that Black wasn't all that concerned with
the idea of being a Hollywood star.
"The most important thing is to be a family
man and I think he's just not over all the
other choices."
Black, who according to CBS, earned his first
film role when he was 11, has mainly worked
on NCIS over the last six years.
Newsweek previously speculated that Black
might be leaving the show to free up time
for other on-screen ventures - like future
installments of the Fast & Furious franchise,
in which he plays Tokyo-based American street
racer Sean Boswell.
Black last appeared in 2015's Furious 7 and
was also in 2006's The Fast and the Furious:
Tokyo Drift.
Rumors of his casting in Fast & Furious 9
have swirled for several years, but Black
was also expected to appear in the eighth
movie in the franchise and didn't.
While it's not clear yet whether Black will
appear in Fast & Furious 9, it's also unknown
whether any movie casting would have taken
him away from NCIS: New Orleans.
As for what's next for the actor, Black didn't
offer any hints about future movie roles in
his own video posted to Twitter after the
death of LaSalle.
Instead, he chose to focus on expressing gratitude
for fans for all of their love and support.
"You were there to celebrate the victories
and to pick me up when I needed it and I appreciate
that."
The actor also indicated he would miss playing
LaSalle, and remains incredibly thankful for
the time he spent on NCIS: New Orleans.
He went on to say that he, quote, "learned
a lot about what the first responders do,"
and that he supports and respects the military.
"A chapter has ended.
What a great journey it was.
Thank you guys so much.
May God bless you."
So far, much of NCIS: New Orleans season 6
has been about LaSalle's search for his missing
brother - whom he then discovers is dead - and
his team's attempts to help him in his quest.
It's not clear where that plot will go after
LaSalle's death - and a preview of the next
episode of the show, excitingly titled "Boom-Boom-Boom-Boom,"
only teases a new storyline involving bombs
in the city.
However, NCIS: New Orleans star Necar Zadegan,
who plays Special Agent Hannah Khoury, promised
that LaSalle's character would have a major
effect on the show.
"LaSalle's character was such a big, important
character to the show.
It does have a big impact on the team in terms
of not just the relationship but personal
stories."
Star Scott Bakula who portrays Supervisory
Special Agent Dwayne "King" Pride, also revealed
that LaSalle's death means change for NCIS:
New Orleans.
"We're off on a big, dramatic change for our
world here for season 6."
While the NCIS franchise is still going strong,
ratings for NCIS: New Orleans have sadly been
declining, according to TV By The Numbers.
Though it's likely upsetting for fans of the
actor, LaSalle's exit just might give the
show a shot in the arm for fresh plot lines
for the rest of the season and beyond.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.